[Music]
in today's morning rounds how just two
hours of walking the week could add
years to your life a new study of older
adults released overnight finds people
who walk six hours or more a week have a
lower risk of dying from respiratory
disease cardiovascular disease and
cancer that is compared to people who
are not active our dr. David agus is
here he's been walking this morning
getting an early start here listen this
is a simple concept but it's something
that we you know everybody I think needs
reminding of because of how beneficial
it can be no question I mean the data
these data show that walking just two
hours a week can start to reduce the
risk of disease heart disease cancer and
respiratory disease and make you live
longer that is pretty impressive data
why is it the perfect exercise well our
bodies were designed to move so for
millions of years we evolved with moving
as part of our daily life and so when
you walk the rhythmic contractions of
the muscles in your legs when you walk
actually make our body work and it's
pretty amazing in that regard your
lymphatic except you're gonna walk
somewhere but the data I mean for our
body to work for our lymphatics to push
things around the muscles have to move
and so it's not just to get your heart
pumping it's actually to make our body
work you actually say that sitting is
the new smoking I don't say that the
data say that and so the data say is
that sitting for five hours a day is
equivalent to smoking almost the pack of
cigarettes and so the key is move every
hour get up and walk around five minutes
it makes an enormous impact and
sometimes you don't even know how long
you're sitting David I wear this I have
a Under Armour ban it says you've been
sitting for an hour and have not moved
and you don't even realize that you're
not doing anything that's why I do you
think a standing desk is better than a
sitting desk which most of us have well
I certainly think you want to move as
much as possible the problem with the
standing desk is you're standing yeah so
in my office for example I have a
treadmill desk and so I go for two or
three you know miles an hour look
there's a picture of you and it's a very
slow pace it takes about a week to get
used to but it's that movement it's the
rhythmic contraction of the legs so
standing desks
they are not as good as a walking desk
or one of those little balancing boards
where you can stand and do that but you
gotta get those muscles activated we
reported earlier about this new research
about about the brain remaining active
after you die explained that first of
all don't experiment with it it's not a
good thing right
but what the data show is is that when
you die which is your heart stopped
moving stops pumping the neurons still
work for a period of time so people who
had heart stopping then came back
they'll describe I heard the emergency
medical attention say he's dead and now
I'm alive again and so there's a period
of time seeing heart stopping and till
the neurons stopped firing and that's
what they're talking about so experiment
with walking but not with this yes walk
walk walk yes all right now we say the
best way to do it is find a friend and
catch up over that walk and then it's
all of a sudden an hour and a half is
gone and you just had a great walk thank
you dr. David have a look for a friend
yeah friends oh wow thank you dr. David
I have friends all the time